maintenant au training
[Applaudissements]
oui j'ai du mal à comprendre ce qui se
passe
20 du studio présente sa première série
sur dix seraient plus
un truc qui cloche ici où on a des
choses à leur façon au regard des
si pour vous c'est
nous sommes chez nous et tout est en
train de s'écrouler
alors il faut qu'on se batte
[Musique]
- ma vision et il est incorrigible
maintenant en streaming sur dix n'est
plus
nous sommes vraiment un couple pas comme
les autres nous n'avons pas de chansons
même pas d'alliance on peut remédier à
ça je le veux et toi chez lui
[Applaudissements]
j'aime arriver j'en ai bavé son mari
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
mais c'est la grande vedette dix
spectacles
et ils vécurent heureux et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants
[Musique]